so as Donald Trump's obstructive
replacement of Attorney General Jeff
Sessions with a dude who thinks the
molar investigation should end and has a
plan to end it explodes in his face
Donald Trump is now increasingly
pretending he just has no idea who this
Whittaker guy is when obviously he knows
exactly who Whittaker is he selected
Whittaker because he knows exactly who
Whittaker is
Whittaker said that if you aren't a New
Testament Christian you shouldn't be a
federal judge the company he advised
world patent marketing is under FBI
investigation he indicated very clearly
that he would try to end the Moller
investigation by starving into funds in
a CNN op-ed about a year ago earlier
this year and there are now reports from
inside the White House that they're
realizing this could be a total disaster
for them so now come the word games in a
very strange video where Donald Trump
appears to enter what I call a talking
point coma Donald Trump repeating 3-4
times in a very bizarre video clip with
a helicopter wailing in the background
that he doesn't know Matt Whittaker but
that he's widely respected what does it
truly mean to know a person in the sort
of Aristotelian sense don't Trump
seemingly getting all philosophical on
us because he's met Whittaker like a
dozen times let's take a look at clip
number one here well Matt Whittaker I
don't know Matt Whittaker Matt Whittaker
worked for Jeff Sessions and he was
always extremely highly thought of but
he still is but I didn't know Matt
Whittaker he worked for attorney general
session he was very very highly thought
of and still is highly thought up but
this only comes up because anybody that
works for me
they do a number on them but Matt
Whittaker is a very smart man he is a
very respected man in the
a law-enforcement community very
respected at the top of the line and
actually the choice was greeted with
raves initially and it still is in some
circles on you know it's a shame that no
matter who I put in they go after him
it's very very sad I have to say but
he's acting I think he'll do a very good
job and we'll see what happens but I
will say this Matt Whitaker is a very
highly respected man
and you didn't have any problem with
Matt Whitaker when he worked for Jeff
Sessions he's respected by law
enforcement he's a very strong law
enforcement personality and person don't
know him highly thought of don't know
him
words for Jeff Sessions highly thought
of very respected very highly respected
respected by law enforcement very
strongly respected by law enforcement
then Trump was asked have you spoken to
Whitaker specifically about the Russia
investigation and Trump went into the
exact same talking point coma I didn't
speak to Matt Whitaker about it I don't
know Matt Whitaker Matt Whitaker has a
great reputation and that's what I
wanted I also wanted to do something
which frankly I could have brought
somebody very easily from the outside I
didn't want to do that when sessions
left what I did very simply is take a
man who works possession again he worked
for Jeff Sessions he's a highly
respected man especially by law
enforcement and I think he's going to do
a great job he's there in an acting
position
he's a probably from what I hear a very
strong person a very strong personality
and I think that's what they need didn't
speak to him don't know him great
reputation worked for sessions respected
by law enforcement he's only acting very
strong strong personality respected
don't know him but a lot of that so not
only was Trump repeating these
meaningless talking points he also was
lying okay there's a Washington Post
report out which says very specifically
Trump does know Matt Whitaker he's met
with Matt Whitaker he's spoken to Matt
Whitaker about the Russia investigation
quote as Jeff Sessions chief of staff
Whitaker met with the president in the
Oval Office more than 12 times normally
accompanying the Attorney General
according to a senior administration
official when Trump complained about the
Moller investigation Whitaker often
smiled knowingly and nodded in assent
last month
Trump literally told Fox News I know
Matt Whitaker now he says eight times in
a minute and a half I don't know Matt
Whitaker and again this is only possible
if time moves backwards rather than
forwards and we are now in a period of
time that is before a month ago right
that's the only way that this is true
Whitaker also doesn't have a good
reputation he worked for that scam
patent company after losing the 2014
Iowa Republican Senate nomination and
the company has been shut down is
totally fraudulent and by the way Trump
in the same little impromptu press
conference told black reporter Abbey
Phillips that she asked a stupid
question at this point it is way too
commonly happening that non-white
journalists are being treated like crap
by Donald Trump take a listen to this
that's up to him
[Music]
what a stupid question that is
what a stupid question but I watched you
a lot you ask a lot of stupid question
so particularly unhinged Trump on this
day to go back to the main point it
would be logical and it would be fine
for the president to know the person
he's putting in as Attorney General
we would hope that the president knows
the person that he's putting in as
Attorney General it would be strange to
put in someone as Attorney General that
you just don't know
and it appears pat that Trump sees the
fallout from this entire thing and he's
lying about every last detail and
Whittaker must be stopped that's the no
matter which area of concern is the
primary area of concern for you the
constitutionality of the appointment
Whitakers involvement with a company in
under investigation by the FBI the fact
that Trump is lying about Whittaker
which is another red whatever you are
most concerned about Whittaker has to be
stopped I was really wondering how the
Trump propaganda arm would respond to
the Trump's contradiction here I know
mat Whittaker I don't know Matt Whitaker
I was like there checkmated there's no
way they can come back from this he's
clearly caught in a lie turns out I
underestimated them because Kellyanne
Conway said that the President does know
Matt Whitaker but he's not like a
longtime friend that he's known for his
entire life and you know he's only gonna
be acting Attorney General for a few
weeks anyway
they found the way out they always seem
to find their way out yeah they he knows
him just well enough for the appointment
to make sense but not well enough for
there to be any selection here based on
what Matt Whitaker's plans are with
regard to Robert molars Trump Russia
investigation amazing how they were able
to just thread that needle ever so
perfectly make sure that you're
following the David Pakman show on
Instagram we have been featuring some of
the top comments from our viewers on
this and other stories there the show is
on Instagram at David Pakman show while
you're at it follow me on instagram as
well at david pakman quick break back
after this on just a huge huge news day
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka it's amazing
it's an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a 15 minute audio
book you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is
t-dot-com
/p a ke ma n